qu'est-ce qu'ils offrent cinq millions dix
points de cash grey qu'est-ce que Genie
demande 820 à Donnell un qu'est-ce que tu
penses que je pense que nous avons leurs couilles cool
alors euh quand est l'audition ce n'est pas une
audition Benji je te l'ai dit oui
désolé une fois un test d'urine le  la réunion
est vendredi à dix heures le studio veut juste
voir que vous avez les yeux brillants et la
queue touffue mais l'accord dépend
de la viande qu'ils veulent juste protéger
la franchise je suis la franchise goo goo
goo joob qui va te chercher  ce n'est pas ce que
tu vas manger j'écoutais une
cassette très intéressante du Dalai Lama
sur le chemin du retour dis ce que tu aimes de la
politique l'homme est un pro du Tibet libre le
Tibet n'est pas libre de se coucher c'est très
cher j'ai le reçu  d'amazon
pour le prouver de toute façon les bouddhistes disent une
prière et ms genie va être là elle
pense que je la veux ou non